[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit gundula
gause und christian sievers
einen guten abend in ein protest in
russland braucht mut weil er geradezu
zwangsläufig dazu führt dass man
festgenommen wird weil schon der
gebrauch bestimmter worte für die
staatsmacht als verbrechen gilt ein
grund warum es flächen deckenden
massenprotest bislang nicht gibt stoppt
den krieg glaubt der propaganda nicht
hier lügen sie euch an das haben jetzt
aber millionen menschen gesehen es steht
auf dem plakat einer redakteurin während
der hauptnachrichten des russischen
ersten kanals
und dann wird weggeschaltet die
demonstranten wurde festgenommen
wir wissen nicht was mit ihr jetzt
geschieht wir wissen was der krieg auch
heute anrichtet in der ukraine petra
otto hat die übersicht
nein es sind nicht immer dieselben
bilder jeden tag sind es neue und immer
mehr mehr zerstörungen mir leid es mir
tut die russischen truppen sie
verstärken ihren druck rund um die
hauptstadt für die ganze welt soll
erfahren was die russen in der ukraine
anrichten
verhandelt haben sie heute wieder
vertreter der russischen und der
ukrainischen seite vierte runde diesmal
per videochat und wieder ergebnislos
morgen soll es weitergehen
und der ukrainische präsident der heute
in einem krankenhaus verwundete soldaten
besucht und orden verteilt er wird der
durchhalteparolen nicht müde
wir fügen dem feind solche verluste zu
dass er gar nicht weiß woher reserven wo
er hilfe finden soll es ist bedauerlich
aber wir haben nicht das recht uns
auszuruhen
kein ausruhen die russische armee sie
rückt immer näher attackiert städte
entlang der grenze hin zu russland aktiv
zum beispiel aber auch in den
separatisten gebieten lohans kunden
jetzt soll us angriffe geben von
ukrainischer seite
die 1,5 millionen metropole steht wohl
unter dauerbeschuss bekannt als
universitäts und theater statt jetzt ein
trümmerfeld kämpfe tote und verletzte
auch in den separatisten gebieten ganz
im osten des landes hier bilder aus
lohans und ausdauer jetzt melden pro
russische kämpfer einen schweren angriff
durch die ukrainische armee mindestens
20 tote also wieder nur schlimme
nachrichten ist nicht ganz
die ukrainische vize ministerpräsidentin
sie zählt heute morgen zehn korridore
auf die menschen aus den kampfgebieten
heraus und hilfsgüter in diese hinein
bringen sollen gibt es jetzt vielleicht
bald auch für die menschen in mario pohl
hilfe dieser höllen dort zu entkommen
nicht mehr so ausgeliefert zu sein
wir haben keinerlei informationen wir
wissen nichts es ist wie ein leben im
finsteren wald das russische
verteidigungsministerium
spricht heute von einer
massenevakuierung aus mario pohl nach
ukrainischen angaben kommen die
hilfsgüter wieder nicht durch keine
klaren informationen
es ist wie in einem finsteren wald
unfassbare bilder nach deutschland an
der tankstelle kann man wahlen verlieren
so gesehen ist es keine überraschung
dass die bundesregierung jetzt
verspricht die folgen des krieges für
deutschland abzufedern und zwar schnell
die zeigen sich ja bereits in rasant
steigenden preisen für energie und
tanken aber eben nicht nur ob und wie
die regierung ihr versprechen halten
kann ist offen eine reihe von ideen ist
in der diskussion noch diese woche soll
es konkrete entscheidungen geben wie die
wirken und was passiert wenn der krieg
noch lange weiter geht viele
fragezeichen david hat an den zapfsäulen
in deutschland wird derzeit besonders
frust getankt pendler leiden im
transportgewerbe ist gar von existenznot
die rede verbraucher im rewe-markt
aldi-markt egal wo wird das am
joghurtbecher schon berge oder an der
milch dass die regale leer werden der
druck die spritpreise abzufedern wächst
doch das vieh ist in der ampel hoch
umstritten so schlüpft finanzminister
lindner kurzerhand in seiner rolle als
fdp-parteichef lindner um eine markige
idee ein krisenrat kraftstoffe zu
verkaufen beim bezahlen an der
tankstelle soll der rabatt abgezogen und
den betreibern anschließend vom bund
erstattet werden für wohl mindestens 20
cent pro liter der tank rabatt ist ein
instrument um in der breit zu wirken für
alle privaten haushalte alle pendler
alle autofahrer alle gewerbetreibende
kritik kommt postwendend von den
besonders betroffenen branchen 20 cent
helfen ein bisschen ist sind aber
eigentlich ein tropfen auf den heißen
stein eigentlich bräuchten 40 bis 50
cent damit dass mittelständische
deutsche transportgewerbe auch zukünftig
die versorgung der bevölkerung
sicherstellen kann und nicht in die
insolvenz rutscht die vorgeschlagene
lösung wird einfach deswegen nicht
klappen weil freie tankstellen diese
vorfinanzierung von 20 cent pro liter
über längere zeit nicht vornehmen können
damit geht jede tankstelle in eine freie
tankstelle zugrunde nach lindners
unabgesprochenen vorschlag hängt der
koalitions segen schief besonders der
grüne koalitionspartner
sucht kaum noch den ärger zu verbergen
alle erzählen dass im moment ein
bisschen was ihnen gerade so sinnvoll
erscheint ich glaube klug ist es mal
sich zusammenzusetzen alles systematisch
aufzuarbeiten und dann die richtigen
entscheidungen zu treffen in einer zeit
wo wir sehen wie verwundbar und die
abhängigkeit von den fossilen macht
jetzt eine verbrauchs prämien zu setzen
sondern auf maßnahmen die auch im
bereich energiesparen und
energieeffizienz wirken ich glaube all
das findet sich im moment in dem
vorschlag von herr lindner noch nicht
wieder wenn zwei sich streiten freut
sich die opposition die genüsslich noch
kritik draufsatteln wir müssen aufpassen
dass man eben nicht am ende rabatte für
menschen macht die eben mit sehr dicken
autos die sehr viel sprit verbrauchen
durch die gegend fahren und ein hohes
einkommen haben das kann sich ja jetzt
nicht die zielsetzung sein ich sehe
nicht wie ein rabatt gutschein
unbürokratisch sein soll die
tankstellenpächter müssten das auch
vorfinanzieren insofern bleiben wir bei
unserem vorschlag steuern senken
mineralölsteuer mehrwertsteuer der
parteivorsitzende lindner hat es
geschafft mit seinem krisen rabatt
vorschlag alle zu überraschen und viele
gegen den finanzminister lindner
aufzubringen
der bundesfinanzminister will also einen
spritpreis rabatt guten abend christian
lindner guten abend herr sievers das
klingt jetzt so ein bisschen wie punkte
sammeln an der zapfsäule wie hoch soll
denn der rabatt seien in ihren augen die
opposition sagt jetzt schon mindestens
40 cent pro liter damit etwas nützt
ja wir sollten uns an der marke von zwei
euro orientieren das sollte beim beginn
dieser maßnahme der orientierungspunkt
sein wir dürfen die familien die pendler
und auch die gewerbetreibende mit den
stark steigenden spritpreisen nicht
allein lassen das ist nicht die einzige
entlastungsmaßnahmen die wir brauchen
aber es ist eine wichtige und dringliche
wenn sie sagen an der marke von zwei
euro orientieren dann heißt das sie
wollen die preise durch diesen rabatt
quasi künstlich drücken dass man am ende
nur noch zwei euro zahlt auch wenn der
preis zwei euro 40 ist wir werden jetzt
wenn es nach mir geht einmal 1 vorschlag
machen für einen fixen krisen rabatz
kraftstoffe der könnte 30 oder 40 cent
betragen und der ist dann fix an der
zapfsäule wird der reguläre preis stehen
damit sehr klar transparent wird es ist
eine zeitlich befristete
maßnahme um die menschen in dieser
schwierigen phase zu unterstützen
übrigens die vorschläge der union sieht
die agrar von 40 cent gesprochen die
vorschläge der union würden auf 14 cent
hinauslaufen weil nach europarecht mehr
steuerlich nicht möglich ist weshalb
mein vorschlag ja ein ausgezahlter
rabatt ist und die tankstellen müssen
das dann zwischenfinanzieren ist denn
das nicht wahnsinnig kompliziert nein
das wäre nicht das modell es ging nicht
darum dass gewissermaßen die einzelne
tankquittungen abgerechnet wird sondern
die
mineralölgesellschaften würden die
gesamtmenge an tausenden liter sprit
benzin und diesel beim start vorlegen
auf der ebene würde dann der staat
interagieren nicht auf der ebene der
einzelnen tankquittungen das wäre nicht
administrierbar und es soll ja gerade
schnell sein auch ein grund warum ich
änderungen im steuerrecht nicht für
empfehlenswert halte weil wir schnell
agieren müssen änderungen gar des
europäischen rechts brauchen monate
mindestens viele wochen herr lindner bei
der eeg-umlage anfang des jahres haben
wir gesehen der staat senkt aber die
verbraucher merken am ende nichts
dasselbe droht doch jetzt auch wenn die
preise nämlich weiter steigen dann haben
sie unsummen an steuergeldern ausgegeben
aber der effekt verpufft man muss das
einbetten zum einen in ein gespräch mit
den mineralölkonzernen
eingebettet werden muss es in eine
ermutigung an das bundeskartellamt und
die markttransparenzstelle zu arbeiten
und herr sievers mir ist wichtig dass
der reguläre preis weiter an der
zapfsäule steht auch wieder ein grund
warum ich nicht an den steuern etwas
ändern will da würde der preis an der
zapfsäule sinken ich möchte dass
deutlich wird was ist das wirkliche
preisniveau und dass es sich wirklich um
einen eingriff des staates unserer
staatlichen solidargemeinschaft handelt
um die menschen zu entlasten beim sprit
übrigens auch die gewerbetreibende
gewerbetreibenden mit einer geringen
gewinnmarge die ebenfalls um ihre
existenz fürchten berlin bei dieser
sache ist es wie immer der
bundesfinanzminister zahlt aber eben
nicht aus eigener tasche am ende zahlen
wir alle unsere kinder im zweifel schon
im aktuellen haushalt ist ja ein großes
fragezeichen drin alles nur vorläufig
der krieg ist nicht einberechnet die
bundeswehr soll milliarden bekommen
corona gibt es auch noch das heißt über
die kosten die gesamtkosten von alledem
was da im moment gerade auf uns
einprasselt haben sie den überblick
verloren nein das ist gar nicht der fall
wir haben sie haben einen sinn haben sie
jetzt geplant der nur vorläufig ist und
wo sie ganz viele fragezeichen dran
gemacht haben ja sie haben gesagt ich
hätte den überblick verloren das ist was
anderes als das was jetzt gerade gesagt
haben herr sie was den übersicht ist
sehr klar für den kernhaushalt also für
das was wir in diesem jahr vorsehen an
regulären ausgaben haben wir einen
klaren plan der plan entspricht den
eckpunkten der vorgängerregierung obwohl
wir steuerentlastungen vorsehen die cdu
csu und spd nicht geplant haben obwohl
wir mehr tun zum beispiel für die
bildung und obwohl wir auch noch
ausgaben im zusammenhang mit der korona
pandemie hatten trotzdem nicht mehr
schulden als die vorgängerregierung
unter anderen vorzeichen geplant hat es
gibt zum zweiten ein sondervermögen für
die bundeswehr das ist zweckgebunden für
die ertüchtigung der streitkräfte nach
15 jahren vernachlässigung das im
grundgesetz abgesichert und es ist damit
auch klar zweckgebunden und dann und
jetzt komme ich ihnen entgegen aber es
heißt nicht die übersicht verloren zu
haben wir sind in einer nichts klar
absehbaren situation wer weiß welche
humanitären verpflichtungen sich aus den
flüchtlingen für uns ergeben die wir in
deutschland aufnehmen denen der schutz
und unterstützung
wer weiß wie sich der krieg in der
ukraine entwickelt wer weiß wie es
wirtschaftlich weiter geht und dafür
werden wir einen ergänzenden haushalt
vorlegen weil das gegenwärtig leider
niemand wissen kann ganz kurz noch
einmal
alles was wir jetzt besprochen haben
sprit preisrabatt wie hoch stehen die
chancen dass dies am ende durch kriegen
auch gegen die grünen
^ ^ christian lindner der
bundesfinanzminister vielen dank
und das gespräch habe aus termingründen
vor der sendung aufgezeichnet und shs
partnerstadt von istanbul genua
liverpool eine hafenstadt mit großer
geschichte der mit abstand wichtigste
hafen der ukraine die hälfte aller im-
und exporte laufen über ihn das macht
odessa zu einem strategisch wichtigen
ziel den menschen dort ist das bewusst
[Musik]
das ensemble der oper von odessa vor dem
prächtigen wahrzeichen der stadt der
gefangenenchor aus nabucco singen gegen
den krieg katrin eigendorf ist in mode
die altstadt von odessa am tag 19 des
krieges freiwillige haben barrikaden
gebaut
eisenbahnschienen zu panzersperren
zusammengeschweißt achtung minen heißt
es auf diesem schild nur mit
sondergenehmigung kommen die menschen in
viele der straßen der weg frei nur für
anwohner soldaten dürfen wir ohne
genehmigung nicht filmen aber mit den
menschen können wir sprechen ich treffe
viele die sich in ein leben im
ausnahmezustand eingerichtet haben
ich habe angst aber ich gehe nirgendwo
hin ich bin alleine ich weiß gar nicht
wohin ich gehen sollte ich habe hier
mein leben verbracht ich bleibe hier
wie in vielen städten der ukraine haben
sich die bürger auch in odessa
organisiert want your freiwillige nennen
sie sich sie packen kisten für die
soldaten an der front mit lebensmitteln
und warmen decken tarnnetzen und
sandsäcken irina korschunow ska ist
rechtsanwältin und wie viel hier ist sie
entschlossen in odessa zu bleiben trotz
der wachsenden gefahr
wir müssen hier alles tun um zu gewinnen
und danach werden wir unser land wieder
aufbauen denn wir lieben es sehr ich
möchte kein flüchtling werden dafür
werde ich beten und ich werde hier bis
zum ende bleiben
die meisten geschäfte sind längst
geschlossen viele menschen vor allem
familien mit kindern haben die stadt
verlassen im café ocean drängeln sich
die zurückgebliebenen noch gibt es
cappuccino und latte macchiato doch das
gefühl von normalität ist schon lange
verschwunden
wer wollte er ist längst weg alle
anderen sind geblieben was haben wir für
eine wahl weg laufen dann werden wir
unser ganzes leben lang weglaufen
ungeheuer
weglaufen keine lösung das denkt auch
irina sie ist russin kommt aus dem ural
und lebt seit über 20 jahren in odessa
der schmerz über das was ihr heimatland
der ukraine antut ist ihr anzumerken
es ist eine furchtbare situation
ich habe in russland viele freunde und
auf der krim aber sie haben sich zu
zombies entwickelt sie meinen hier
passiert nichts das sei eine sache
zwischen den mächtigen aber die
bevölkerung leidet
hoffnung auf waffenruhe auf
verhandlungen zwischen russland und der
ukraine
niemand in odessa den ich an diesem tag
treffe hofft darauf und so bereiten sie
ihre stadt darauf vor die nächste zu
sein die russland umzingelt
die quirlige stadt am warmen meer einen
babylon aus der zarenzeit in odessa
waren wir immer weit weg von der macht
sagen sie dort und spüren jetzt dass der
krieg näher kommt gundula hat jetzt
weitere nachrichten zum thema im blick
bundeskanzler scholz hat gemeinsam mit
dem türkischen präsidenten erdogan einen
sofortigen waffenstillstand in der
ukraine gefordert ebenso wie sichere
korridore für zivilisten
zentrales thema von scholz
antrittsbesuch in der türkei war der
krieg der russische präsident müsse in
erhalten so scholz es können nur eine
diplomatische lösung geben gegenüber
präsident erdogan würdigte scholz die
vermittlungsangebote der türkei zugleich
sprach er aber auch differenzen bei
demokratie und menschenrechten an
verstärkte anstrengungen für den schutz
von vor dem krieg geflüchteten kindern
und jugendlichen fordert
bundesentwicklungsministerin schulze sie
hatte sich an der rumänisch ukrainischen
grenze über die situation der
flüchtenden informiert übersiedelt und
sie rät kommen derzeit täglich etwa 1200
menschen nach medien vor allem frauen
mit kindern die meisten von ihnen
wollten möglichst schnell wieder zurück
in ihre heimat erklärte die ministerin
danach in einem interview mit dem
heute-journal update
nach un angaben sind seit kriegsbeginn
mittlerweile mehr als 2,8 millionen
menschen aus der ukraine geflohen in
deutschland wurden bis heute knapp
147.000 kriegsflüchtlinge registriert
die tatsächliche zahl könnte aber höher
sein da keine systematischen kontrollen
stattfinden der landkreistag fordert
eine gleichmäßige verteilung der
geflüchteten um regionale über
belastungen zu vermeiden
wenn sie den menschen in der ukraine und
jenen auf der flucht helfen wollen dann
können sie spenden beim aktionsbündnis
katastrophenhilfe ivan de 65 104 106 100
104 106 100 stichwort zdf nothilfe
ukraine weitere informationen unter
spenden zdf de oder im zdf text auf
seite 8 190
bundesverteidigungsministerium lambrecht
hat die geplante anschaffung von f 35
tarnkappenjets als wichtigen schritt
bezeichnet mit diesen derzeit weltweit
modernsten verfügbaren
kampfflugzeugen sei auch die nukleare
teilhabe deutschlands gesichert
35 dieser jets sollen angeschafft werden
und die veralteten
tornado-kampfflugzeuge ersetzen die f35
des us herstellers lockheed martin sind
bereits für den einsatz mit atomwaffen
zertifiziert
ein thema das alles andere verdrängt
weil es so enorme auswirkungen hat das
ist der krieg gegen die ukraine er hat
auch ein thema verdrängt das davor
selbst viele andere verdrängte sie
merken schon jetzt wird es kompliziert
denn dieses thema ist nicht weg es zeigt
sich in den zahlen die korona inzidenz
in deutschland steigt von höchstwert zu
höchstwert
es zeigt sich im täglichen leben weil
jede und jeder von ihnen gerade jemanden
kennen dürfte die oder der sich das
virus eingefangen hat gleichzeitig gibt
es in vielen ländern um uns herum
mittlerweile praktisch keine
beschränkungen mehr leben wie früher und
auch in deutschland sollen die meisten
schutzmaßnahmen auslaufen in einer
knappen woche wie gefährlich ist die
lage also wirklich dieser frage sind
dagmar 0 und ulrike röttger nachgegangen
die infektionszahlen so hoch wie nie
zuvor die korona waren app im dauer
krisen modus doch wer sich ansteckt hat
meist milde symptome soll und kann sich
deutschland also leisten weiter zu
öffnen
bundesgesundheitsminister lauterbach
klingt nicht sehr optimistisch lage ist
objektiv viel schlechter als die
stimmung kritik an den geplanten
eröffnungen kommt von vielen seiten auch
von ärzten zu viel zu schnell heißt es
und dennoch es geht jetzt nicht darum
jede infektion zu verhindern was gar
nicht geht bei einem virus was derartig
ansteckend ist wie eben das coroner
virus sondern es geht darum jetzt die
folgen zu minimieren und vor allen
dingen die immunität in der bevölkerung
hoch zu halten das geht einmal mit der
impfung aber auch durch die natürlichen
infektion und genau das findet jetzt
statt ab sonntag so der plan soll
generell nur noch der sogenannte
basisschutz gelten masten pflicht nur in
öffentlichen verkehrsmitteln testpflicht
in gefährdeten einrichtungen sollte sich
die lage extrem verschlechtern können
hotspot regelungen in kraft treten über
die entscheiden die länder
professor torsten lehr von der uni
saarland erstellt seit beginn der
pandemie prognosemodelle zum
infektionsgeschehen den anstieg der
zahlen hat er damit vorhergesagt eine
überlastung der intensivstation scheint
ihm bei omikron nicht wahrscheinlich er
sieht eine ganz andere gefahr die
problematik dabei ist natürlich dass wir
dann auch sehr viel aktive fälle haben
das heißt so sehr viel menschen die mit
der erkrankung dann in quarantäne gehen
müssen um dort dann natürlich dann auch
der gesellschaft nicht mehr als
arbeitende bevölkerung zur verfügung
stehen das sind zurzeit etwa zwei
millionen schon ohne öffnungs schritte
könnte sich diese zahlen mehr als
verdoppeln da sehen wir hier das
eigentlich in dem fall sogar schon hier
zu knapp fünf millionen leuten kommen
die eben zu hause sind und dort
letztendlich da nicht der arbeit
zugänglich sind das wären etwa zehn
prozent der arbeitenden und eine öffnung
könnte die situation noch einmal
verschärfen doch die deutschen wollen
raus aus der pandemie wir können uns
diese öffnungen nicht nur leisten wir
müssen sie uns auch leisten denn wir
dürfen nicht wie laien den fehler machen
immer nur auf ein aspekt zuschauen wie
jetzt zum beispiel eben auf die pandemie
der profi muss alles im blick haben auch
die anderen parameter auch die schäden
die man natürlich setzt durch pandemie
maßnahmen über zwei jahre pandemie eine
gefühlte ewigkeit die regierenden müssen
nun diese woche entscheidungen treffen
wie es weitergeht entscheidungen deren
folgen so oder so erst später sichtbar
werden
die beyond gründers reggie und ugur
sahin sowie die biochemikerin katalin
carico haben eine weitere renommierte
auszeichnung erhalten den paul ehrlich
und ludwig darmstaedter preis geehrt
wurden sie für ihre medizinische
grundlagenforschung und die spektakulär
schnelle entwicklung des m rna
impfstoffes gegen korona der preis
würdigt auch die aussichtsreichen
perspektiven der medizintechnologie vor
allem im kampf gegen krebs
im skandal um den insolventen
zahlungsdienstleister wirecard ist nun
anklage erhoben worden gegen ex
konzernchef markus braun und zwei
weitere frühere topmanager fast zwei
jahre nach der milliarden-pleite valerie
wie sieht man das an der börse die ja
auf den skandal hin ihr regelwerk
reformiert hat gut so denkt man hier
wirecard hat im ruf der deutschen börse
geschadet denn einen pleitekonzern im
dax dax hat es davor noch nicht gegeben
und schon gar nicht einen der mutmaßlich
in einen milliardenschweren
bilanzbetrug verwickelt ist die
staatsanwaltschaft erhebt nun schwere
vorwürfe gegen ex vorstandschef braun
und zwei weitere ehemalige
spitzenmanager bilanzfälschung
marktmanipulation untreue und
gewerbsmäßiger bandenbetrug
jahrelang sollen sie bilanzen gefälscht
und banken geschädigt haben um über 3
milliarden euro auch tausende anleger
darunter etliche kleine anleger verloren
viel geld wirecard aktien waren mal fast
200 euro wert heute nichts weiter als
ein pennystock seit fast zwei jahren
sitzt ex chef brown in untersuchungshaft
er weist alle vorwürfe zurück im
erwarteten strafprozess soll geklärt
werden war brown einen milliarden
betrüger oder so unfassbar naiv dass er
wie er behauptet nicht merkte die
mitarbeiter milliarden stahlen ihm
drohen bis zu zehn jahre haft wirecard
das war mal deutschlands große find
hoffnung vor zwei jahren brach das
kartenhaus zusammen insolvenz weil
sagenhafte 1,9 milliarden euro fehlten
die staatsanwaltschaft glaubt das geld
hat es nie gegeben weiterer
hauptverdächtiger
ex-vorstand marschalek ist untergetaucht
in russland vermutet man
vielen dank valerie nach frankfurt
wegen des bahnstreiks des
sicherheitspersonals an sechs deutschen
flughäfen sind heute hunderte flüge
ausgefallen
und auch morgen ist mit erheblichen
beeinträchtigungen im flugverkehr zu
rechnen da der ausstand auf frankfurt
ausgeweitet werden soll die gewerkschaft
verdi will mit den warnstreiks einen
neuen tarifvertrag für die bundesweit
rund 25.000 sicherheitskräfte erreichen
drei verhandlungsrunden waren bislang
ohne ergebnis geblieben
sportlich waren die paralympischen
winterspiele ein voller erfolg für das
deutsche team neun medaillen darunter
vier mal gold brachten sie heute mit
nach hause so wie anna lena forster die
mit der deutschen mannschaft nach neun
wettkampftagen wieder in frankfurt
landen das team mit vielen paralympics
neulingen erreichte im medaillenspiegel
platz sieben und übertrifft damit alle
erwartungen
der us-schauspieler und
oscar-preisträger william hurt ist im
alter von 71 jahren infolge einer
krebserkrankung gestorben seit den 1980
er jahren machte sich hört einen namen
als
charakterdarsteller und feierte viele
kinoerfolgen für seine rolle in der kuss
der spinnenfrau erhielt er 1986 den
oscar als bester hauptdarsteller
drei weitere male war er für den
wichtigsten preis der filmwelt nominiert
und wenn sie die chance haben sich
william hurt als nachrichtenmoderator
anzusehen im film nachrichten fieber
broadcast news wir haben es eben ganz
ganz kurz gesehen dann tun sie das das
hat zwar mit der realen redaktions welt
hier nicht so wahnsinnig viel zu tun
aber es ist enorm unterhaltend
garantiere ich die kunden versprochen
aus unserer redaktion meldet sich um
23.45 ganz real christopher wehrmann mit
dem heute-journal abdeckt und morgen ist
an dieser stelle marietta slomka für sie
da von uns allen hier in ein angenehm
amt
[Musik]
ein stück umarmte und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter der regen des
heutigen tages hin mit diesem tiefe
zusammen und das verabschiedet sich
allmählich nach nordosten das nächste
tief kommt schon von südwesten heran und
bringt morgen vor allem der mitte
deutschlands südlich des mains etwa bis
zu 20 liter auf den quadratmeter in 12
stunden außerdem nähert sich warme luft
richtung frankreich die erreicht uns
dann am mittwoch und bringt sogar
saharastaub mit das liegt hauptsächlich
an diesem tief vor spanien vor der
iberischen halbinsel die punkt diese
wärme aus nordafrika zu uns wir schauen
in die nacht und da gibt es im nordosten
viele wort mitreden das verabschiedet
sich langsam in der mitte ist es
vielfach stark bewölkt teilweise neblig
im südwesten kommt in den frühstunden
dann neuer regen auf und das bei
tiefsten temperaturen von minus zwei
grad nach osten hin und +5 grad richtung
niederrhein morgen am vormittag ist der
regen dann im südwesten deutschlands
angekommen es regnet dann kräftig sonst
ist es trocken mit etwas sonnenschein
zum nachmittag verlagert sich das tief
dann in die mitte und hier entlang des
mains gibt den meisten regen und auch
nach osten deutschlands im norden aber
durchaus sonnige abschnitte mit höchsten
temperaturen von 14 grad richtung osten
und südwesten 16 grad dort wo das tief
als erstes an kommt nur bei sieben bis
neun grad maximal die nächsten tage gibt
es durchaus viel sonnenschein am
mittwoch zum beispiel bis 19 grad und
weiterhin relativ warm damit ein schöner
abend